you heard it from the man the man who
knows him the man who has worked with
him played with them surely has his text
number and todd and i assume can thumb
out some messages and get some messages
i i think that even though it's gronk
being gronk at first
and i like how the guy
feigns ignorance as to why gronk gave
the number he gave i mean he may as well
wear that number but uh later he'll be
back he'll definitely be back i
hey look i look for any evidence that
bolsters my beliefs and rob gronkowski
gave me that evidence in that response
he thinks he's coming back chris i think
he's coming back well you know again
it's great okay
he doesn't know that he does not you
know and yes
we can have a little friendly wager on
this i mean i pay out my wagers i ate
the damn uh actually it wasn't even a
wager i just did that other goodness of
my heart and ate your damn chocolate
pretzel and all that that's not a wager
the wager is the steak dinner that you
owe me from three years right well i
mean okay you gotta come you you gotta
come back up to the office at some point
time and then i'll i can pay you back
all right so that'll happen i didn't
forget about that don't be a jerk but
all right no
regardless getting back to that
i just feel like it's gotta this has got
a different tone
and again i know gronkowski he knows
that edelman's the ultimate competitor
and he's probably to a degree thinking
yeah that you know this is something
where if he can get back healthy he'll
want another crack at it or whatever
else but you know again like
rob gronkowski didn't have
that type of moment when he left
football where he sat down and i'm
retiring and shed tears and really
fought them back and do all that because
i he knew there was a chance he might
come back i think this is one with
julian edelman again to to his own quote
the wheels have fallen off he has a
blown tire from everything i know just
even last year it was strugglesville for
him to play when he did play i mean it
was a real like i gotta manage my knee
and leg you know every minute of the day
so in my heart of hearts again we can go
double or nothing on that steak dinner i
think it's over for julian i don't think
he's got anything more in the tank
let me ask you this question then
why
didn't he retire
why why why was he released by the
patriots he could have just retired and
they put him on the reserve retired list
he ended up being released by the team
failed physical designation free to sign
with another team so if the buccaneers
would want him and he would want to play
for them no complications no draft pick
compensation for the patriots like they
had to do for rob gronkowski who was
never playing for the patriots again
they got something for gronk's rights
because he was on the reserve retired
list why wouldn't edelman if he truly is
retired and never coming back why
wouldn't he just go on the reserve
retired list well okay one
maybe they don't they'd look at it and
go wait even if he does go somewhere
else he doesn't have much to offer maybe
they know that like he's he's you know
banged up goods but two you know and
again i don't know the answer to this i
i i you know i wish i maybe would have
looked this up a little bit or thought
thought about this but is there there's
got to be some benefit to the patriots
with him doing that contractually too no
i mean is there something there's any
there's nothing there that benefits them
the benefit is put him on the reserve
retired list because if he ever wants to
come back
that team that wants him has to go
through you
the benefit is putting him on the
reserve retired list and if you're going
to have this big production at gillette
stadium capped with foxboro forever and
he says he's retiring a patriot and he's
never playing again there's no reason
not to go on the the reserve retired
list
there's no there's nothing that gets
kicked down the the road as far as
salary anything like that i mean yeah
it's done it's over he doesn't get paid
anymore either way doesn't get paid
anymore i don't have an answer i don't i
don't know i don't know why they did
that i figured there was some reason
just as far as balancing checkbooks or
whatever else that made sense for the
from the patriots aspect to do that but
no i mean listen that's a good question
i don't know either i don't know what
that means
if he does join the tampa bay buccaneers
it would be presumably at some point
later in the season closer to the end of
the run have him ready for the
postseason if it does happen until then
nothing stops him now from hanging out
with tom brady and possibly joining the
tampa bay buccaneers players who will be
with tom brady working out at the local
high school if you if you work out at
the team facility jules can't be there
if you work out wherever jules can be
there just like some thought antonio
brown was there last year for those
off-site workouts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports